North Korea's State media released this
video which appears to show the recent
launch of North Korea's Hua song 18
intercontinental ballistic missile Japan
confirmed it flew for more than an hour
rising to a height of more than six
kilometers achieving North Korea's
longest ever missile flight time
the leaders of South Korea and Japan
were meeting on the sidelines of the
NATO Summit in Lithuania when the launch
took place on Wednesday
North Korea launched an ICBM again this
is a threat to peace and stability in
the region and the world it's also
provocation and an obvious violation of
U.N resolutions
the United Nations security Council has
adopted at least nine major sanctions
resolutions against North Korea in
response to its nuclear and missile
activities since 2006 but it hasn't
stopped the launches in fact the tests
are increasing schedule
North Korea's launch of an ICBM
threatens the peace and safety of the
International Community and we strongly
condemn it
North Korea says the Hua song 18 is a
part of what it calls its core Nuclear
Strike Force a warning to the United
States and its allies
it's designed to hit the continental
United States it's not designed to hit
through local targets it's one of the
really big ones which we've all sort of
seen on the internet and that is always
for the Americans particularly that's
you know the set that's particularly a
threat Pyongyang accuses Washington of
increasing tensions in the Korean
Peninsula by deploying submarines and
bombers to the region in reaction to the
launch the U.S conducted military
exercises with its South Korean Ally in
a show of force Mike level Al Jazeera